[Music] Do
n't be scared, it feels so good.
What is it, Princess? Oh look, the lady from your address is also here. It's
true.
[
Music] Princess, let go of my hand.  It does
n't hurt, are you okay?
Princess, what are you
panicking about?Prince Abel hugged me, but I've already experienced it during a dance, and
besides, Prince Abel is still a child,
eight years younger than me, so the princess must have been
injured somehow.  What did you do?
[Music] It
's okay if you don't look at me like that. Could you please just walk
away? Oh, I'm sorry.
Don't misunderstand me, Abel. It's
not that I don't like being attached to you as a prince.
[Music]
Oh, I know,
but my heart is tingling and I feel
restless. This must be Abel. If the
prince hates me, he won't send reinforcements,
so I'm just panicking, but what
can I do?
Wow, Prince Abel.  Thank you very much for your help.
People
naturally distance themselves from others when they are approached more than necessary.If
Prince Abel could experience that, he should be able to
clear up any misunderstandings.Now that he understands, I'm sure he
won't be able to distance himself from me for a while.
Look, you turned your head away, too.
That's because I felt the same way as Prince Abel did earlier.
I'm also sensitive, so I
get nervous when people get too close to me than necessary. That's all.
Well, my feelings are the same as those of the three princesses,
but I'm sure my feelings are
stronger than yours.Oh, I hate losing.I
guess you want to say that I'm more sensitive.But Miya didn't realize that,
Abel.  The reasons for her nervousness were slightly different for Miya and Miya,
and the fact that Miya herself was
also nervous after being approached by a boy she was slightly interested in.